on Saturday white nationalists neo-nazis
and members of the alt-right but I
repeat myself gathered in
Charlottesville Virginia to chant
stupidities and be maced by left-wing
and act anarchists before one apparent
brown shirt rammed 20 protesters with
his car murdering one and injuring the
rest we'll discuss how the OL tripe goes
so wrong Plus lone conservatives Cassy
Dylan roaming millennial and The Daily
wires Jacob arey joined the panel of
deplorable z-- to discuss neo-nazis
losing their website Obama's election
collusion with Russia and for some
reason Colin Kaepernick I'm Michael Nolt
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
what a weekend that was I woke up I
tried to figure out some other story we
could cover today because I know
everybody is going to be covering this
but there is nothing else we have to
talk about it I I wrote it I wrote a
piece of that six months ago about the
alright kind of a fairly in-depth study
of them so we'll talk about that a
little bit today as I was watching it
this weekend though it did feel like the
iran-iraq war it was a pity that both
sides couldn't lose you had one New York
Times reporter witnessed this is a quote
she she's had to recant recently but she
did tweet this out quote the hard left
seemed as hate-filled is all trite I saw
Club wielding an Tifa beating white
nationalists being led out of the park
quote among my unanswered questions
police response why did things get out
of hand so quickly could the violence
had been prevented
and this has been a huge criticism why
were the police apparently doing nothing
why was all this violence allowed to
happen why weren't there barricades why
weren't these little fights being put
down I don't know there isn't a lot of
video footage out there of it but a lot
of questions to answer with regard to
that the event was called unite the
right and this was so clever this was a
clever move of these the whole event was
white nationalist neo-nazi all focused
on race but they called it unite the
right now here is the organizer
describing the event at the event so I'm
outside of City Hall in Charles go right
now the Charles Ville City Council just
held a press conference where they said
that they were going to cancel the
permit for unite the right they want to
move it to McIntyre Park this area
that's across the way that doesn't have
a damn thing to do with the robert e lee
monument that is the first and foremost
reason that we're having this rally is
for that park and for that statue
it's about white genocide it's about the
replacement of our people culturally and
ethnically and that statue is the focal
point of everything there is no way
there is no way we are going to move
that demonstration out of Lee Park you
heard him that is the focal point of
every
robert e lee the Confederate monuments
that is the center of it all that was
Jason Kessler who is the organizer of
this but they called it unite the right
by the way here's and here's another
tweet he sent out from another event he
said getting ready to speak at the free
speech rally in front of the Lincoln
monument Lincoln can go to hell I'm a
southern man I think we see where he's
coming from other people who were
helping to organize and appear at this
event were Richard Spencer well-known
white nationalist of the National Policy
Institute he runs all right calm and
radix journal KKK showed up David Duke
showed up the lot of neo Confederates as
well but they called it unite the right
because they do have a little bit of
intelligence they do have a little
political forethought and they realized
that if they called it unite the right
then that would aid in the mainstream
media narrative the inevitable
mainstream media narrative to lump all
right wingers in with this event all
conservatives in with this group of
racists but then further if it's cold
unite the right very few people are
going to pay close attention to this
then perhaps conservatives would defend
these guys in their little protest and
they would therefore insinuate
themselves more and more into the
conservative movement the mainstream of
right-wing culture now there is a lot of
misunderstanding over what the alt-right
is and what the alright isn't most of
that was caused by mileage innopolis who
for a year said he is alright he isn't
alright he's a proponent of the alright
but he's not on it he made a lot of
contradictory claims in a long piece
that he published on Breitbart calm on
the one hand he says that the racists
make up a small fraction two to five
percent of the alright on the other hand
he says that all the central figures in
the alright are white nationalists and
are racists themselves he names these
people like Richard Spencer Jared Taylor
who's a fellow Yalie and runs American
Renaissance white nationalist
organization a lot of the Neo
reactionary movement Curtis yarv and
Mencius mold bug a lot of people who
have been associated with racism online
so the question is where does the
alt-right go so wrong
we love the memes we love Pepe and we
don't like the the Nazi stuff so luckily
we have some video of Richard Spencer
leaning you alright proxies on patrons
at Bell's instance see both adopting
event controls but as I mean goodbye
sense see Boyer compromise no ste paint
again rainy enough it's not how many
times do I have to tell you that I don't
speak German Marshall how many times
before it's similar I guess do we have
any to have a clip in English well for
that we'd have to go all the way back to
the time of Karl Marx who is of course
no wait that's Paul blah that is I
understand the confusion because the
Michael null shows on Paul bought does
look eerily similar to Richard Spencer
for those of you listening this is why
you should subscribe because the
resemblance is absolutely uncanny but no
that is a Richard Spencer ether not
doing sorry Sir Richard's bends are
created all right calm he he's credited
with coining the term alright he's a
major figure in it he holds an annual
conference with the National Policy
Institute and he has been a leading
figure in this movement here is the old
introductory video to his website who
are you
I'm not talking about your name or your
occupation I'm talking about something
bigger something deeper I'm talking
about your connection to a culture a
history a density an identity that
stretches back and flows forward century
an identity you can glimpse in the face
of a grandparent or your child that is
so creepy if you can't see that video it
is so we're I take back the Paul blog
comparison Paul Bois is James Bond
compared to that guy he is Cary Grant
compared to Richard Spencer it but as
creepy as the video is it does raise an
important question a question of
identity who are you what is essentially
your identity now what Richard Spencer
is saying is your identity is white your
identity is European or European descent
or whatever people have lots of
identities I'm a New Yorker I live in
California I guess I'm a Californian I'm
a podcaster I'm an American a lot
a lot of identities going around what he
then gets to is Western civilization
what is Western civilization what is the
identity of Western civilization now
traditionally we would describe this as
Athens in Jerusalem the meeting of Greek
philosophy with Christianity and the
history that that made threat all of
Europe the Holy Roman Empire the the end
of the Roman Empire
the the Crusades the the modern era the
last 500 years that all of these things
that the West produced the natural law
that came out of Christianity and the
National Rights that came out of that
and the liberal democracy that came out
of that our own national culture as
Americans and as Westerners which led to
Human Rights this that and the other
thing but what does the alt-right take
on this foundation of the west are you a
Christian I'm a cultural Christian yeah
what the hell of that but you know I
many of us struggle with faith but uh
but I find a hard as acrylic allows you
can't call yourself you can't call
yourself a cultural Christian and then
say I struggle with faith I see a you
profess with Jesus Christ your Lord and
Savior I know I have in my life I I
don't I mean look what's an audition on
me no no no actually no is an interview
but but see what somebody tells me
they're Christian and I'm again I'm half
old surely Christian what is coach uli
Chris I grew up in a Christian
background i resonate with christianity
and so on so this isn't a complicated
question but Richard Spencer makes it
complicated he's a cultural Christian
and obviously that concept doesn't
doesn't mean anything but it like with
all of these guys a little bit of
knowledge is a dangerous thing the
alt-right people are just smart enough
just articulate enough just educated
enough to convince dummies to follow
them it is like the New York Times
editorial board who are just there I
would like to clarify too I am comparing
the New York Times editorial board do
they all right nail it up for a variety
of reasons but this is that issue the
what what does Richard Spencer worship
what he likes the idea of Christianity
but he doesn't like the doing of
Christianity he doesn't like the Jesus I
say this often but lefties 10
want the semblance of a thing without
the essence of the thing you know
they're like decaf coffee they want to
have a university degree but not have a
university education they want to use
the image of Martin Luther King but they
don't want to deal with the content of
his actual speeches and we're seeing
this exact same thing from from the
alt-right you know a culture that
becomes navel-gazing ultimately dies it
can't just look at it so that's what
look somewhere else do we have clip 7 of
Richard Spencer talking about religion
thinking about where does religion come
come from like how does it evolve and I
think one way to think about it is that
like religion blank culture I mean
there's no I mean like the origin of
where culture is cult you know I mean
it's it's the religion and culture it's
hard to even separate them but it's a
way of like of binding a community and
in having authority while not
necessarily having power so you know if
I'm if I'm leading an army I could say
you know fight they're going to kill you
so you better fight them and if you
retreat I'm going to shoot you you know
good luck boy you know that's a that's a
got a like brutal way of of you know
ordering your troops around and
commanding troops but you know the way
we've seen this in throughout history
and not definitely not just modern
history ancient history prehistory is
that you're fighting for let might not
be fighting for an ideal like democracy
or something but you're fighting for
something bigger it's like God is on our
side that is exactly right that that's
why I wanted to play that whole long
clip because he gets it exactly right
and then he gets it completely wrong
culture comes from cult a culture is
defined by what you worship what you a
color that worships money will be a more
materialistic culture a culture the
worship sex will be a more lusty culture
and but a culture can't worship itself a
cut that Western culture is a culture
that was born out of Christianity
culture that worshipped God in a
particular way in particular place and
it produced wonderful things works of
arts civilization
government's political rights the the
greatest civilization that's ever lived
but a man wrapped up in himself is a
very small package indeed and the same
is true of cultures so if the culture
just trapped is trapped in its own
existence it can't become greater than
itself it can't grow it will it will
just die so Richard Spencer he
recognizes the importance of
Christianity he recognizes that it's the
essence of the Western civilization but
he himself doesn't worship it because we
live in basically a quick post Christian
society a post Nietzsche society in
which God has apparently did spoiler
alert he isn't really dead but according
to the culture
he is so here is Spencer's idea of how
to have his cake and eat it too do you
think that uncocking the church would be
a great asset to our cause good question
well again this is one of those
questions that could a book could be
written on this but a corgi on clucking
the church would be a benefit and I
would support that and adopting that as
once religion I think we did turn
Christianity into something European we
did you could say pagan eyes it or
German eyes it in many ways I'm not I
don't want to ever be seen as someone
who you know wearing a fedora and is a
shrill atheist who that war with
Christians and things we needed you know
deconstruct the church first or anything
I'm really not like that effectively
liberalism and modernism are Theological
replacements for Christianity they are
post Christian also also entirely true
until he becomes entirely wrong
liberalism modernism certainly modernism
have become a replacement theology but
there are plenty of replacement theology
so there's communism there's
environmentalism there there's the sort
of cult of tolerance that we're seeing
now play epic Google and elsewhere they
are replacements for Christianity but
white nationalism is to fascism
is to white supremacy is to Nazism were
also movements that have become
theological and taken the place of
Christianity in the West and this is
also in particular nothing new even in
the figure of Richard Spence
we've seen it before with George Lincoln
Rockwell the head of the American Nazi
Party in the 1960s same thing buttoned
up wore tweed smoked a pipe parted his
hair nicely and discussed the same ideas
rockwell when he was a little boy was a
Protestant and then he abandoned his
Protestantism when he discovered that
God isn't true you know God isn't real
he had his atheist awakening but he
recognized the importance of
Christianity and the usefulness to
society into civilization so he decided
that we need to sort of use it in some
way he didn't consider the fact that
possibly it's all true and there's a
reason why that culture flourished for
certainly all of modernity and for 2,000
years but no it had to be some strange
trick and how do we recapture to trick
this is what we're seeing in this post
Christian West we're seeing it
fundamentally a contradiction and
impossibility - you want to have the
Western civilization without the thing
that makes it the West and the term that
a lot of these online all writers are
using is a red pill so you remember from
the matrix oh we have a clip of it this
is your last chance after this there's
no turning back you take the blue pill
the story ends you wake up in your bed
and believe whatever you want you take
the red pill you stay in Wonderland
and I show you how deep the rabbit-hole
goes
so that's the choice that they think we
have they think that we're living in a
fantasy the fantasy of 2017 Western
civilization its illusory and what we
really need to do is wake up to the
truth of reality which is dark and ugly
and it's a hard truth but you know we
got to do it take the red pill the world
is ugly but let's let's go ahead and do
it anyway horace walpole the great
english writer said life is a comedy to
him who thinks and a tragedy to him who
feels so is life just a hellish facade
full of pointless moments until we turn
into warm food or is there some purpose
I can't possibly answer that I have to
bring on our panel of deplorable and we
have an excellent one today we have
roaming millennial we have the lone
conservative Cassie Dylan and for some
reason we have Jacob arey
Cassie welcome is your first time here
so you will get the first question but
you know this is a there's a real
softball the West has been grappling
with it for only about a century or
century and a half is God dead
absolutely not I'm a devout Christian
and I think it's kind of telling to see
that these alt writers have advantage
Jesus obviously they never believed in
Jesus in the first place if they're
spewing these type of things out there
making it seem like God's creation which
was humanity is not equal so it also
doesn't surprise me to see those those
videos they need to show to Richard
Spencer I haven't seen them before I
tried not to pay attention to him
flawlessly it doesn't shock me at all I
emailed him actually here I twittered
him he and I follow each other on
Twitter I was somebody every toe was
jokes but he only follows me because I'm
the only non Jew at the Daily wire which
might be I don't know I'm not sure but
anyway he didn't get back to me in time
for this show maybe he'll send in a
message or something but is it I mean I
agree with you God isn't dead that's
manifestly true but you know roaming is
Spencer's vision the natural outcome of
a post-christian right wing or is there
a more coherent atheist right wing that
doesn't mow down people at protests well
I just go by the middle anything about
sorry go ahead
go ahead well I think what's interesting
about Richard Spencer that you know he
kind of coined the alright he likes to
parade himself around under the
right-wing label but if you actually
- what'd you say he is a literal
National Socialist that I'm not saying
that you know trying to equate him with
Nazi then you know fear monger that way
I am I think the guy is a Nazi I think
it's pretty good but maybe you want to
get a nice year Stan is actually in
favor of National Socialism like he I
interviewed him on my channel and you
asked him about non ethnic cleansing
policies that he might be in favor of
Edina he's in favor of things like you
know socialized medicine the same same
thing with you know environmental
protections that we see coming from the
far left he is not a right wing person
and I think that kind of extends to his
views on conservatism and Christianity
as well I think in his mind he sees
things like the regressive left does
where it's like anything white is right
wing which is actually not how it works
right don't don't you think though that
there is some that it's a little
disingenuous to say they have nothing to
do with the right
I only agree entirely they like big
government they want socialized medicine
they view the world with the same
identity politics as the left but all
those guys voted for Trump do we have to
take some ownership of them or can we
say they're lefties they have lefty
premises well we could we can take
ownership of them in so far as you know
Trump wants the wall and they're anti
Mexican and they see that as a good
thing but if we're talking about like
you know their actual ideology what
their beliefs are what their economic
beliefs are what they are on the
authoritarian libertarian scale they're
very very far from I think the emerging
new right which is a right-wing actually
right wing and be culturally libertarian
like these are authoritarian leftist
maybe center-left but I mean if we're
actually going to tackle what their
political ideology is these aren't you
know these aren't Tea Partiers for
example right let me sorry Meghan Cruz's
of the party yeah you know that guy
Andrew Anglin the head of daily stormer
he used to be a hippie he used to be a
vegan dreadlocks he was a member of the
left so I certainly grant it's an easy
leap from the far left into Nazism but
Jacob William F Buckley Jr famously
purged all those racists out of the
party but sometimes they can be useful
if we can take their votes what do you
think do you think there's any big 10
argument to
suck up to them or do we just have to
purge them I'm all for purging them
these these same people are the same
people who say I'm a part of white
genocide because I happen to be married
to a Mexican and who's also part Native
American so I have I have absolutely no
sympathy for them I think that they
should be purged out of any movement
whether whether it's conservative or
liberal I don't think we should pander
to these guys at all 100% I'm I'm
against giving them even a bone
you know else purged people with the
Nazis because are you well I was just
going to say Jakob advocating for
purging people right go ahead well I
guess we're an all right show now I
don't know I was fast
I am think we're doing that sorry Cathy
did you have something to say sou us
started talking yeah I was just going to
add on the I just met from the Middle
East and I saw deeply religious people
and me in America we do have a secular
society obviously there are religious
people in America you can go to New York
you'll see buried about Jews you go done
style will see Village about Christians
but it's not the same over there but I
don't necessarily think that religion is
going anywhere I think these guys are
pretending that Christianity is no
longer believing in Christ but it's just
your identity you know it's still
believing in Christ going to church
being with your family and believing God
well I think it's just crazy that
they're just trying to pretend those
things listening right they love
Christendom they love christened him but
they hate Christianity they don't see
some contradiction in between those two
it's the idea of it right it's the idea
of uniting people behind one person but
then they want to pervert it absolutely
all right I've had enough of the Nazis
we need to move on to really important
stories Politico is reported oh by the
way I got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube that you you you cheapskates
you have such a good panel today you get
Kathy Dillon roaming millennial even
Jacob Airy and you won't be able to see
the rest unless you go to daily wire
comm and subscribe it's only ten dollars
a month
100 dollars a year you get my show the
ben shapiro show the Andrew Clavin show
and best of all the leftist here's
tumblr keeps your leftist here's hot or
cold always salty and delicious go over
there right now daily wire calm and
we'll be right back
Politico is reporting that President
Obama was warned as early as 2014 that
the Russian government intended to
interfere in Western elections but they
did nothing
Kassie can we say perhaps that Barack
Obama colluded with the Russians I don't
want to go into the whole Russia
including collusion honestly I think
it's just insane and I think the right
is trying to fight back to the left by
fighting them with their own tactics I
don't think anyone necessarily colluded
with the Russians so I think the
Russians got involved yes so I think it
went more than just trolling on the
internet no I don't think it's as big as
people were making it and I don't think
Obama necessarily clued them either I
think he just kind of went along with it
I know he had that secret conversation
that he was caught in a hot like which
was interesting but I think this whole
Russia inclusion thing machines would
die down sounds like the sort of thing a
girl who colluded with the Russians
would say Rahming why did they ignore
this is it because Hillary was a shoo-in
because they wanted to leverage it
somehow or because they just didn't
think it would matter whatsoever
all of the above yeah I think if we look
at the timeline of this whole Russian
collusion narrative I think even you
know even the leftist media didn't even
think that it would stick as much as it
has I think they've just been kind of
going with it throwing whatever they
have and just seeing hey you know this
is actually working let's do it more so
yeah I mean you know I'm no fan of Obama
but I kind of agree with Cassandra I
don't think this was you know Obama in
cahoots with the Russians I think you
know if there was anything I don't think
with anything serious and you know I
hate to see people you know Republicans
they're you know people in the GOP just
trying to distract from what's going on
on our side by explaining the same
accusation set of people I want to
distract as much as possible this is a
terrible story it makes us look awful I
want to talk about I want to do exactly
what they did and only talk about this
Russia nonsense but Jacob roaming brings
up a good point there's very little
coverage of this there was may one one
headline in Politico today is this
evidence that the mainstream media is
only interested in Russia when it backs
up their Trump narrative or is this
really just a kind of nothing story that
we'd be best to ignore
oh it totally shows the mainstream media
is in league with the Democrats drug is
a good bet both ways I have to agree
with roaming and Cassie I think that you
know we should just let this whole
Russia thing go
the Russians are always trying to cause
trouble for the United States it's
nothing new
there's no evidence that Obama directly
colluded with them and there's no
evidence that Trump directly cluded with
them so the mainstream media just needs
to drop this completely it's not going
and we're until that we find something
that they did something more that the
Russians did something more egregious it
just needs to be let go
fair enough I agree with that I'm done
talking about those Russians now we need
to talk about the most of where I can't
believe this is a story but
unfortunately it's like one of the only
ones today over the weekend Al
Sharpton's National Action Network
protested outside of the Rams preseason
opener because Colin Kaepernick doesn't
have a job if you've forgotten Colin
Kaepernick as I've been trying to he's
that football player who refused to get
up for the national anthem and kneeled
down during it Jacob why doesn't Colin
Kaepernick have a job because he's not
that great of a player now I'm saying
he's on the level of terrible but he
can't get a job because he's not that
great it's the same reason Tim Tebow
can't couldn't get a football job but
and by the way cinchy-bo-binchy or Nick
he even won the Heisman Trophy right but
I still think that everyone on the left
is trying to make this all about racism
and the right is trying to make it all
about the fact that he wouldn't stand
for the national anthem
it's just a plain flat fact that he is
just not that great of a player and
that's why he doesn't have a job but
that doesn't sell newspapers that
doesn't get Alex
Katzie is sitting down for the national
anthem sufficient reason not to rehire a
mediocre football player or is that
should that not be considered I think
this is a bigger trend if you look at
anyone who is in an industry that
doesn't have to do with politics the
second they soil themselves politics
whether it's less or right oftentimes
there's that the rest that you might be
soiled you know you might not be able to
go back into your your industry without
being seen in certain way for instance
when you have people like Snoop Dogg
coming out making these videos with
politics and what were they being rude
to our president starting to kill them
basically
you are as pretty rude to yourself you
will don't want to see that they want to
listen to music they don't want to hear
about politics they don't want to hear
about your your view they just want to
see you playing a football that's true
celebrities don't if celebrities don't
tell us about their political views who
will we simple non celebrity people know
who to vote for tell us I only pay
attention to Snoop Dogg and Richard
Spencer those are the owners where I get
my political views Romo averaged out to
service between them you should be good
yes absolutely it does bring I mean is
this quest should we consider what they
do culturally I mean this was one single
act he's kneeling down for the pledge of
allegiance and actors in Hollywood get
away with this stuff all the time the
Oscars are unbearable these days because
every speech is some stupid Patricia
Arquette screed about Trump or imagined
wage differences or something like that
is there is there any reason that we
should that sports should be different
or is everything of a piece well you
know the thing these are entertainers
aren't really like regular employees
where your employer you know as long as
you do your job you get a regular salary
right calling Colin Kaepernick oh my
gosh I I don't know football join the
club
yeah his job yeah he plays football but
his main job is to like bring in viewers
and sponsors right and if people are put
off by his political message then yeah
he's not good for the team and that us
the same with actors if people get tired
up of someone let's listen like Sean
Penn did they don't want to see the
movie isn't he's in anymore
then yeah people aren't going to hire
him it's not necessarily even whether
you know the directors or the team
owners agree with them or not it's just
about business and you know consumers I
think for the most part we're able to
kind of distinguish between these are
your personal views and this is you as
you know in your job but after a while
it just get kind of tiring and I think
that football player guy definitely
can't help a nap you should use it
Kaepernick oh gosh yeah it's only best
roaming I know even though I preached us
a white last name but yeah he is for
nobody has the right to throw a football
on
if the advertisers want you out then you
know you're an entertainer I suppose
first and foremost Cassie I'm gonna give
you the final word on this why do I care
why do i why does anybody care about
this man why is this been dominating the
news for a year I'm still searching for
the reason I think the over media is
maybe getting sick of talking about
Russia but now it's back to Colin Capri
another checklist was the airplane Colin
Kaepernick and now this the Russia story
so now we're going back to Colin
Kaepernick's about airplane goes down
soon I'm sure we'll talk about that for
a few months - cycle never ending that's
an amazing prediction from the panel of
deplorable czar I get out of here
Cassie nice to have you on roaming
wonderful as always
and Jacob now it's time for the final
thought I have to put my smart glasses
on for the final thought because I can't
read the prompter a little bit of
knowledge is a dangerous thing so if you
want to defend Western culture which is
a laudable and urgent endeavor you might
first ask yourself what is Western
culture what created Western culture
what does Western culture comprise white
nationalists like Richard Spencer seem
to answer with shallow pop philosophy
and slick memes now that's a great thing
to unite the right but not with the
wrong
all right reads Nietzsche conservatives
understand Nietzsche and there are more
things in heaven and earth than are
dreamt of in our philosophy this eternal
fact should suffice to keep people out
of hell unless like the clowns who
paraded through Charlottesville this
weekend they're already there and
determined to drag us down into the
filth with them on that I'm Michael
Noel's this is the Michael Nolt oh come
back tomorrow we'll do it again
[Music]
you
[Music]